sada what is uh have have you whatever
ended up happening with uh your issues
with adam did you guys ever talk is it i
ain't talking but
cause i feel like you were kind of a
staple over there at no jumper you were
doing the no jumper news he just was too
media
for me you feel me like with me
you know what i'm saying like i feel
like
like he put it in blank turns he's like
maybe like we ain't friends you thought
i was gonna go cover [__] because
you a rapper that'd be up here and when
he said this [__] i just was like robert
you wanna punch me on my [__] mouth
but i'm just gonna leave you alone bro
and just let that [__] right and then
let it be happy because he gonna get his
carpet you know what i'm saying right
right that's all that [__] is bro
it was more interesting i wanted to go
up there and do [__] for the [__]
yeah it was more in terms of
you guys thought you were friends
no i thought i thought i
i i don't know what he thought i thought
you feel me yeah yeah for sure i thought
he was my own boy
[__] ass white boy
what's that feel me and when a [__]
don't want it
when you're trying to talk to a [__]
and keep on trying to talk to him
and
he keeping his disposition on [__] i'm
immediate personality i'm gonna cover
and post what i want and
you mad for no reason and all this like
girly ass [__] brian about to keep on
trying so i can talk it out with you
shout out to a.d.a.d tried to make sure
she was straight with it
yeah it is great that's my boy yeah
that's fair
that's what um want stick to your guns